alemany intenta frenar el aumento
descontrolado de los contagios porque
hoy 19 luego de 16 días de récords de
casos positivos el gobierno debate si
vuelve obligatoria la inmunización
contra el coronavirus el país tiene una
de las tasas de vacunación más bajas de
europa apenas el 68% de los ciudadanos
ha recibido la pauta completa razón por
la cual cinco jefes de gobierno
regionales ya se han mostrado abiertos a
considerar la obligatoriedad de la
vacuna durante una reunión de
representantes de la unión europea el
ministro de estado alemán abogó por la
dosis de refuerzo
ya que tenemos nuevos hallazgos
científicos de que la dosis de refuerzo
es un gran éxito si las vacunas de
refuerzo están a la orden del día los
estudios científicos demuestran que la
efectividad de la vacuna aumenta
nuevamente de manera significativa con
esta dosis extra de mansiche
test en la ciudad de colonia centros
deportivos y de conciertos se
convirtieron en puntos de vacunación
para los que quieren esta dosis
ya mis sets quería recibir una vacuna de
refuerzo que se ofrece aquí y todavía
había citas disponibles venir aquí en
automóvil también es bastante cómodo
libre de mauro for fun can siempre
noticia muy bien en su intento
desesperado por proteger a los sistemas
de salud sobrecargados alemania y otros
países de europa imponen reglas que
limitan las opciones para los no
vacunados en la capital alemana sólo las
personas que estén inmunizadas podrán
acceder al comercio minorista con la
excepción de los establecimientos donde
se venden productos de primera necesidad
que seguirán abiertos a los no vacunados
aunque algunos mercados de navidad'
decidieron cerrar el de berlín seguirá
abierto